FIRED FROM HER JOB.
I'M TRACE GALLAGHER, NOW BACK TO
"HANNITY" ."
>> Sean: WELCOME BACK TO THIS
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY."
NO EVIDENCE OF ANY TRUCK RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THIS
IS HAPPENED.
REMEMBER THE PAUL MANAFORT
INDICTMENT, THE GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS GUILTY PLEA, THEY
LEFT FOR AN HISTORIC TRIP TO
ASIA AND SECRETARIES,
SECRETARY SANDERS THAT THE POPE
MAY BE HURTING THE U.S. AND TIES
WITH MOSCOW.
THEY MAY BE TRYING TO DERAIL THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY IN MORE WAYS
THAN ONE.
JOINING US NOW, THE AUTHOR OF
THE BEST SELLER, "TRUMP'S
AMERICA."
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
NEWT GINGRICH.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE SUCCESS WITH
TRUMP IN YOUR BOOK BUT YOU ALSO
HAVE THE WARNINGS, WARNINGS AND
WARNINGS AND WHAT THE PRESIDENT
NEEDS TO BE AWARE OF.
OBVIOUSLY I STAND ON MY ORIGINAL
PREMISE.
MUELLER IS OUT FOR BLOOD.
MUELLER PICKED THIS TEAM OF
DEMOCRATIC DONORS AND EVEN
CLINTON'S OLD LAWYER AT THE
FOUNDATION, ANDREW WEISSMANN AND
COMPANY, FOR A REASON.
HE WANTS TO HURT THE PRESIDENT
AS BADLY AS HE CAN AND THAT'S
WHY HE'S OFFERING ALL THESE GET
OUT OF JAIL FREE CARDS.
I THINK WE OUGHT TO QUIT TALKING
ABOUT THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION,
AND THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT.
IN FACT TO CREATE A NONJUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
JUSTICE, A NONJUSTICE DEPARTMENT
COUP D'ETAT IN WHICH THEY UNDO
THE VOTES OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THEY PILE ENOUGH JUNK AROUND
THAT THEY GRADUALLY OVERWHELM
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF YOU START AND LOOK AT
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE BEEN DOING,
AND THIS WAS NEVER ABOUT RUSSIAN
COLLUSION OR FINDING THE TRUTH.
THIS WAS ABOUT A METHODICAL
EFFORT TO DESTROY
PRESIDENT TRUMP BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE THINGS
THEY ARE GETTING INDICTMENTS ON,
SOMEBODY GOES AND LIES TO THE
CONGRESS, THAT STUPID AND THEY
DESERVE TO GET INDICTED.
THEY WERE LYING ABOUT STUFF THAT
WASN'T A CRIME.
THAT'S THE POINT THAT ANDY
McCARTHY KEEPS MAKING AS A
FORMER JUSTICE DEPARTMENT LAWYER
THAT NONE OF THE UNDERLYING
PATTERNS WERE CRIMES AND PEOPLE
WERE ALLOWED TO BE IN BUSINESS.
AND OF COURSE WHAT SHE GETS IS
THE HEADLINE IN THE MEDIA WHICH
IS ANOTHER TERRIBLE BLOW TO
TRUMP.
WHAT IT IS IS, FURTHER PROOF
THAT MUELLER'S INTEREST IS IN
DESTROYING THE PRESIDENCY.
THEY HAVE NO REASON TO RELEASE
THIS AS THE PRESIDENT GOES TO AN
IMPORTANT MEETING IN ARGENTINA
WITH 19 OTHER WORLD LEADERS.
>> Sean: YOU'VE BEEN THE
MINORITY IN CONGRESS AND THE
SPEAKER IN CONGRESS.
IT'S MUCH EASIER TO BE THE
SPEAKER I'M GUESSING ALTHOUGH,
YOU'VE TAKEN YOUR FAIR SHARE.
SO, THAT'S NOT GOING ANYWHERE IN
THE SENATE, AND THAT WILL HELP
HIM.
BUT IT'S STILL THE INTENTION.
I DON'T SEE THE AGENDA TO SERVE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> THERE IS A 1923 LAW WHICH
ALLOWS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE WAYS
AND MEANS COMMITTEE TO REQUEST
THE TAX RETURNS OF ANY AMERICAN.
I COULD IMAGINE THE CIRCUMSTANCE
OF THE NEW CHAIRMAN AND LIBERAL
GRANT DEMOCRATS WILL EXERCISE
HIS LEGAL RIGHT AND THE INTERNAL
REVENUE REVENUE WILL TURN OVER
THE TOP TAX RETURNS WHICH ARE
SUPPOSEDLY SECRET IN THE RELEASE
OF WHICH WOULD BE A FELONY.
AND THEN BY SOME MAGIC METHOD
THAT ALL OF US WILL BE SHOCKED
AT, THEY WILL TURN OUT ON PAGE
ONE OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THESE PEOPLE ARE PLAYING FOR
BLOOD.
THIS IS MORE LIKE THE TERROR IN
THE FRENCH REVOLUTION THAT IT IS
IN TRADITIONAL AMERICAN
POLITICS.
THEY WILL DO ANYTHING, BREAK ANY
RULES AND I THINK BREAK ANY LAW.
>> Sean: LET'S GO TO THE
BORDER.
THEY ARE A THOUSAND MILES AWAY,
NOT A THOUSAND MILES AWAY
ANYMORE.
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE PELTED
WITH ROCKS, BOTTLES AND
PROJECTILES.
USING THE SAME TACTICS THAT
OBAMA USED, INTERESTINGLY NOBODY
CARED THEN.
TEAR GAS, THAT DISPERSE CROWDS
THAT WOULD TRY TO BREAK DOWN THE
WALL AND CHARGE INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, PRETTY SEVERE CRISIS
IN MEXICO.
THEN YOU HAVE 600 CRIMINALS
IDENTIFIED BY DHS THAT HAVE
INFILTRATED THE CARAVAN.
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE?
HOW DO YOU STOP THAT FROM
HAPPENING?
>> FIRST OF ALL, EVERY CITIZEN
SHOULD ASK THEIR DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN OR SENATOR, ARE YOU
REALLY COMFORTABLE WITH 600
IDENTIFIED CRIMINALS COMING INTO
THE UNITED STATES?
IN JUST ONE PARTICULAR WAY, ALL
THE PEOPLE COMING NORTH IN THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS WILL BE AMAZING.
I THINK IT'S IS ASTONISHING TO
ME THAT SENATOR SCHUMER, SPEAKER
PELOSI, NOBODY IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN YOU GET A
REPORT FROM THAT APARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY THAT IN THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP THERE ARE 600
PEOPLE WHO ARE CONVICTED
CRIMINALS.
THAT WILL NOT BE ON
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," AND THAT'S
AN ASTONISHING PIECE OF DATA.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT SIMPLY HAS
TO COME BACK HOME AND KEEP
DRIVING THE POINTS, IS THE ONE
PERSON THAT CAN BREAK THROUGH
THE NEWS BLACKOUT AND GET THE
TRUTH FOR AMERICA.
>> THEY COULD USE THE PROCESS TO
GET FULL FUNDING OF THE LAW, AN
AND --
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
INDICATED THAT WHAT HE MAY DO IS
SHOUT THE BORDER AND SEE HOW
RAPIDLY THAT CAUSES A REAL PAIN